thank you so much for joining us today
welcome to the r studio enterprise
community meetup this is our finance
meetup today i'm rachel i'm calling in
from our boston office i'm actually in
our studio office today
i'm joined by my co-host dylan lackey
from our finance team as well
dylan feel free to say hello
yes yes hello everyone dylan lackey here
based out of the us in austin texas
i've been in open source software for
many many years helping folks specialize
in
making that jump from open source to you
know more of a robust enterprise
offering um actually rachel is my
predecessor so everything i know i've
learned from rachel so happy to be here
and happy to help out
thanks dylan
if you've just joined now to feel free
to introduce yourselves through the chat
window and maybe say hello or where
you're calling in from
do just want to mention that if you want
to turn on live transcription for the
meetup you can do so as well just in the
zoom bar below if you press the more
button
but to go through a brief agenda for
today we'll just have some short
introductions and then alan will lead us
through their journ their journey
towards a reproducible development
workflow
using a shiny dashboard framework then
we'll have lots of time for questions
and open discussion too
and just a reminder to everyone that the
meetup is recorded so it will be shared
to the r studio youtube after
i'll be sure to put that on linkedin and
twitter and everywhere that i posted
about the meetup too
um but just
wanted to let people know that if you
want to ask questions anonymously
and not be part of the recording you can
do so too i'll put that in the chat
window in just a moment here
but for anyone who is joining for the
first time
and alan if you want to go to the next
slide thank you
this is a friendly and open meet up
environment for teams to be able to
share the work that you're doing within
your organizations teach lessons learned
and network with each other
but really just to allow us all to learn
from each other
so thank you all so much for making this
a welcoming community too
we really want to create spaces where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone
i just
really like to reiterate that we love to
hear from everyone no matter your level
of experience
or the industry that you work in as well
i'll share a few links in the chat if
you
have any suggestions or want to speak at
a future
meetup too
but with that thank you all again so
much for joining us today i would love
to turn it over to our speaker alan
carlson
so alan is
tech lead for the business intelligence
team at snap finance
[Music]
thank you alan
thank you rachel um let me
stop well it's just
that let me reshare my screen
um
yeah uh thanks everyone for
for joining today um so i'm gonna talk
about you know building robust modular
dashboards with golem and graveler
packages
um we will be going through some just
contextual slides make sure we're on the
same page but a bulk of the presentation
will actually be building a uh a
graveler dashboard with
the package
so
as far as
what we're going to cover today just a
quick introduction about myself so like
rachel mentioned i work for snap finance
they're a personal lending firm
for customers across the nation and i'm
the tech lead on the business
intelligence team
i've been
a developer for four and a half years at
the tech league for the past two
and when i started on the team there was
only
me and another developer so we've come a
long way from just two of us to now i
believe
uh eight of us on the team
uh my
academic background is in business so i
have my undergrad masters in in finance
and i'm telling you that because just as
a disclaimer um
since all of my like programming
knowledge is job-based i don't have a
deep understanding of you know the finer
points of programming so if any of those
kind of questions come up i'll do my
best to answer them but i understand
that's not my exact area of expertise
um
so with that out of the way what are we
going to talk about so i just want to
give context into you know the business
challenges that we were facing a couple
years ago you know why we started on
this journey
um
how we tried to answer with gollum you
know what is goal and package how does
it you know help
you know reproduce your dashboards
and then graveler is our answer to what
gold couldn't do for us at the time
and at that point i'll go into actual
like you know coding in r with the the
actual package installation and building
everything
and then once that's done we'll switch
back to the slides for potential
enhancements i've thought about for the
future and then finally q a um so with
that we'll jump into the the business
challenge context so
like i mentioned uh two years ago there
was just two developers right it was me
and another guy and
we had just started working with shiny
at that point up until then markdowns
were sufficient data polls were
sufficient
but the business was growing and they
wanted more interactivity and granular
looks in into their data
and part of this
was
we had legacy code that was being
transferred to our department so the the
data science team had built around you
know these six dashboards that were
pretty complex right they have
you know six to eight different tabs on
a sidebar they all do kind of different
ui layouts and back ends and what we
noticed was that these six dashboards
were all coded slightly differently
right
so the the look and feels pretty similar
but some of them had
pure api back-ends some of them use sql
instead
they had similarly named functions that
did entirely different purposes on the
different dashboards
some used you know select eyes input
versus picker input
and so the
the challenge was you spend all this
time focusing on a dashboard
but when you go to the next dashboard
you can only port like 40 of that
knowledge
with the new intricacies and the in the
new dashboard you're working on
right
and so the the other challenge at the
same time we were facing is we were
about to hire four new developers that
had various you know backgrounds and
skill sets um but they all had minimal
experience with with r and shiny
specifically right
um and so
the questions that we you know were
trying to answer immediately was how do
we standardize our workflow so we can
minimize you know future tech debt with
our dashboards that we build
and secondarily how can i get new hires
to understand what we're doing and start
building dashboards very quickly right
um and so that
when i was you know researching that
problem
we learned about what the golem package
was
and you know currently the golem package
has a very fleshed out github repo it
has a published book that you can either
purchase or view online
but when i looked at it two years ago it
was just this
little book down with
you know five or so sections that
had bare bones concepts and they're
still fleshing out the process
but the the idea of golem is
has stayed the same right they're trying
to build
modular dashboards with a package-based
framework
and before we go into you know what that
means i just want to cover those
concepts really quick with a couple
slides
um so
all shiny apps have the same thing in
common right they use a ui to create a
layout then a server to connect data to
that layout
and so when you build shiny dashboards
there's basically three ways you do so
right the first method is the all-in-one
approach right so you can make a very
simple dashboard with an app.r file
all your codes in one place and you know
it makes
simple dashboards
when you add more complexity you kind of
split the ui and server into their own
files because that separates their
purposes cleanly right the ui has all
the layouts in it the server files all
like the code back end in it
and so you know that each of those is
referring to its very specific parts
and then eventually it lives in like a
single folder right
the third method is called
modularization
and what this does is you know let's say
you want to build a dashboard that
serves
like four different parts of the
business right sales product marketing
and like some executive view
if you try and put all that into one
server file that's going to be a very
large server file which isn't very
helpful
so
modularization sticks all these sections
into their own ui and server for each
individual dashboard piece
additionally this avoids namespace
conflicts that you can sometimes run
into with the other methods
but the key point here is that
when you modulize your dashboards the ui
and server become self-contained
functions that your dashboard will
eventually call when it builds its
dashboard
so that's
so keep that phrase in mind as we go to
the next slide
um you know our packages if you've never
built in our package you've certainly
installed one
um and what a package actually is is
it's a bundle of you know files data
sets unit tests
and individual functions right
whether you're using d plier or ggplot2
if you look into their github repos all
of their functions are tiny little
discrete r scripts that are bundled
together as a package
right
and so there's that phrase again
self-contained functions and so what
golem does what it's
what it's trying to do basically is it
looks at the commonalities between
modularization and package frameworks in
other words golem says well if if all my
modules are just functions already and a
package is just a bundle of functions
why can't i just make my dashboard a
package and run it and deploy it that
way
and the advantage to that is packages
are very standardized right there are
specific folders and directories and
locations where files go within our
package
because of that though
golem has no shortage of creation
options right so if you just install
golem and try and run with their
workflow right there's tons of different
deployment types you can do um either
our pubs r studio connect docker
i believe they even do like github pages
at some point
there's different unit tests you can
create either at like the module or the
app level
again various ways to import files and
different configurations for your your
actual app
and so
when i was testing this out you know i'm
trying to answer those two questions
right does it solve
those two challenges we're facing
standardization absolutely right
packages like i mentioned they have to
be built a certain way in order to work
right they have to have an ins folder a
man folder name spaces descriptions all
that is standard across every single our
package that's ever built but because of
all these
complex options it doesn't do a good job
of communication
to new developers or people that don't
have a lot of experience with r r shiny
and that's by design
if you look at the first page of the
golem book it actually says you know if
you're reading this you have some
intermediate advanced level of how shiny
works on the back end
and this is trying to explore more
possibilities there
so
what do i need to do though
so we built graveler to kind of address
that complexity we take away all those
options we strip them down to the bare
minimum and say here's
these defaults let's run those defaults
and you'll be good to go right um
if you're curious about the name
so
i'm a huge pokemon nerd um and golem
itself is
well i don't believe the golden package
was named after the pokemon golem but if
i'm taking this you know big complex
package and i'm making it simpler the
simpler version of golov in the pokemon
world is called graveler so that's the
name there and i'm pleased to announce
that gravel is available on github
currently
so you can search either github on
or not search github on your hub search
graveler on github
um you can install it with
devtools colon colon install underscore
github gh carl allen slash graveler it's
in a bunch of links in the the blog post
and whatever
so you can install for yourself there
and so with that we will switch
to
my r screen
the powerpoint exits there we go
okay
so i've already installed the package of
course
um when you install it you know you
might run into some library dependencies
uh this is my first really public
package i've tried to do so if you run
into any of that you know feel free to
raise the issue on github
or you know let me know at some point
and i can try and work on
getting those imports correctly and when
you install it you should see
you know point seven five point one
build standards monitor shiny dashboard
frameworks
cool so that's step one
right
how do i actually start building a
modular dashboard right it sounds pretty
complex
um the answer is it's it's not hard to
do with with gravel itself so the first
step you'll make a new project either
with the button up here or of course
file new project
um you can create you know a new
directory
and you might be thinking well
do i go new project new package shine
application none of them because grava
will now have its own
little wizard type down here at the
bottom there is also the golem one right
because if you're using graveler you
have to use golem as a back end
so you can also look into golem for
yourself at any time if you want
but gravel is what we'll be focused on
focusing on for today
so
you'll have just a few simple options
here
directory name i'll just make this r
studio meetup
i'll just make it as part of my desktop
for now
um the package name usually you want
those to be you know pretty short and
sweet
um i
i don't think they run into issues with
special characters but
i know there's no issues with no special
characters so that's that's something to
keep in mind
then over here you have your display
title so in the top left of your
dashboard
that's what the user will see is the the
dashboard title
all right so i'll just call this meetup
and then finally you can put in
we have usernames here
um you can put in like your full name or
whatever it just assigns like an author
so you know who's running that package
right
so
you'll create a project
it takes a few seconds to spin up
but then
here's the default graphic layout right
you have this directory that we just
made has all the necessary files that
you need to build a package
that has the three helpful files to get
you started going right
so before we get into the
first
file here the o1 dev
if you're unfamiliar with packages
this description file is where your
dependencies lay right so whenever you
build a package you have to import
other packages that it might rely on
right so let's say you know you're
trying to build
some custom package that you know uses
the the dplyr summarize function right
you have to import the dplyr package in
order for your package to work right
and
you know with a dashboard you can have a
lot of packages so instead of adding
them you know one by one like this oops
helps if i can type correctly
instead of imports you know
i can type dply or gt.2
but it's hard to remember all of those
right especially if you have you know
half a dozen
libraries to install
so instead
what this 01 file does for o1dev it will
it will add dependencies to your
description and to your package itself
so this is just a vector of the
dashboards
the bare bones dashboards it needs to
work
dashboard themes obviously colors
everything dev tools just in case the
apply or lubridate golem pins shiny so
on and so forth i won't go into what all
those do
so you run the vector
over to my environment here and it runs
a simple for loop it attaches those
package
packages right you'll notice your
console gets very colorful right because
it will add
the package to the imports field in
description right
so if i swing back around to the
description file
tada it has all of my my imports ready
to go
the second part is we need to add an
app.r file for publishing so
rstudioconnect when it publishes a
dashboard it looks for an app to r file
in order to actually tell it that that
file is a dashboard right if i were to
just upload
this directory as it exists
um our studio would throw an air and be
like i don't know what this is this
might be a package i don't publish
packages that's not what i'm here for
instead create like an actual file i can
i can understand right
so you run this line
and you'll notice my comment that says
you know be sure to enter one in the
console prompt
that's because
uh
golem in order to talk like the rest of
the dashboard back end with its
configurations it has to make its own
little
yaml configuration file that's all you
need to do is just hit yes or type one
excuse me
and then you can read through all this
and it basically says user app.r file
here's this golden config yaml file that
we have
you never need to edit those it's just
an automated
file creation for for back-end
deployment
then i won't run this line of code it
takes a few minutes but here at snap
we've integrated with rstudio's
get back content feature
and so what this does it allows you to
write what's called a manifest.json file
which basically takes a snapshot of all
your packages
so that our studio can actually connect
to your github repo find that package
snapshot and then publish from from that
snapshot
it's been super useful because instead
of
worrying about people individually
clicking like the publish button trying
to overwrite stuff you can all work from
the same github repo same github file
and the the dashboards will update
accordingly
right
so then after that's done
you can navigate to the the run.dev
folder because your dashboard is already
ready
this is the second file that opened it
just navigates to that file i'll close
the description one for now
so this is the file that you actually
use to to run your your dashboard
locally
right as far as what all these lines do
the
prod equals false basically prevents
like console messages from printing
or excuse me true prevents console
messages from printing so when it's
false
it allows you to kind of like
debug and develop more usually i just
leave it to false by by default i never
really change it to true
um the the next two lines are important
because it will
detach all your lab libraries and remove
your environment right and that's
important because it needs to
clean your environment so that when you
run your dashboard locally you know
that's going to work exactly with
what's in the dashboard itself right
when i first started working with shiny
i'd run into an issue where it works
locally but not when i publish
because for whatever reason i had some
local variable
that was just never in the dashboard
like none that logic was present so it
works locally because it's trying to
read my local environment
so we wipe the environment to make sure
that the dashboard has exactly what it
needs to run
and finally
again if you're familiar with package
development this is the same thing as
the
package build install and restart
function down here
so this creates a namespace
which is where all of your exports and
imports come from
and then it loads like the meetup
package
and in actuality
you know once you run this line your
package now exists in your local
environment right so i can do meetup
colon colon
and currently there's only like two
functions that are exported from it we
can add more
and finally
once that's done
you run the app
and that's it your dashboard's already
built it has you know the display title
that we made it has a working sidebar
example
it has a collapsible sidebar
over here a fun little graveler logo
that you can change
the colors you can change as well
but
this took long as i was explaining it
but in reality you can run all those
lines in less than a minute right and
you have the entirety of the framework
that all you need to do is just add
modules to
right
which is a good segue into you know how
do i create modules and actually put
content into this dashboard
so if we go back to the on dev file
there's one line that we forgot at the
bottom
which was adding modules
so
with graveler there's called a level up
function
and all you do is you can paste that in
your console
you don't really want to comment out
this line because
this is supposed to be just once or run
once right so i don't really
i just copy the comments and put in my
console
and then we'll call this i don't know
summary or foo or you know whatever you
want to call your name of a of your
module i recommend keeping them small
because it is going to add some prefixes
to this name
um so the the shorter it is the better
while still being intuitive
so
when you run the level up function it's
also going to create two files to open
for you
the mod underscore name or summary in
this case and then the mod underscore
summary
underscore fct display
r
i'll talk about this in a second
but this module is the module code right
this is one section of your dashboard
that that you can make
so you might be thinking oh great well
you put in a box real quick
so you know width equals 12.
i probably need an equal sign there
and i'll do title equals
xbox okay
you think okay cool now i can just rerun
my dashboard right everything will work
that is optimistic thinking because it
will not work because your module has
yet to actually connect to your actual
dashboard layout right and so
you know there's no new sidebar there's
no box over here because you've built
the module but you haven't connected it
to anything right so at the bottom of
every module there are these three lines
that you copy
into their respective files
all right so you have your body.r your
app server.r and your sidebar dot bar so
open all those right now all all our
files located in the r folder itself
here we have app server
body
and eventually sidebar
so you simply just copy all these in
order
it tells you where to add them so i comp
out here adding my module here
for app server oops
[Music]
here
also have a comment you know connect to
a pin board if you use that part of our
studio connect
and then finally
you have your sidebar item
um
technically you don't need the example
there because the example
obviously can't connect to anything it's
just to show that a sidebar is working
so you just delete this line or you can
count it out either or
so this
we'll call the summary
and then the tab name automatically
connects to the the module itself
and then you can use any kind of the the
icon libraries either fontos glyph icon
or whatever
you also don't need to save your your
files i just did but as a force i have
it which is
good i suppose but if you have unsaved
files whenever you run the dev file it
will automatically save
everything in your package before it
tries to build again so pay attention to
app server and body up here
i read these lines of code it saves them
and we'll incorporate those changes
there
so there we go summary text box hooray
and now you can simply add
you know as much ui and server
functionality as you want right that's
that's outside the purpose of this
meeting because this is a back end not a
shiny front end
enhancer
um
so
um
where
was i
trying to figure out the order which i
go through this
um
okay so
now that we have your module you're
probably asking well okay if we have the
module working what is what is this file
what is this fct display file
so in golem their philosophy is you want
to
abstract away as much as you can from
even your module code right so for
example and you could have
a bunch of different charts or tables in
this
but
at the moment your code starts to repeat
itself you want to put that inside of a
function
to
make this as clean and compact as
possible and it's a hard concept to
explain
just verbally so if i'm going so excuse
me i'm going to switch to
the actual graveler package because
inside of it
there is
an example dashboard that's fleshed out
called geodude
[Music]
and it itself has its own little modules
right so i'll show you what it looks
like by default
[Music]
set my working directory
again there you go
so this is the default example you can
also run this yourself with
i
believe what is its graveler
do you do an example as well with no
parameters in it
um
[Music]
but so in this first tab you know you
notice that there are four graphs here
right representing antscomb's quartet so
um with a couple gg plot leads and
whatnot
so how did i build this right did i
write a gg plot code four different
times no because you know let's say
someone tells you i want to change those
dots from a horrendous lime green to an
actual human visible color
so in my module
here's my ui right i have
just a two by two grade of charts
and you'll notice in my plotlist renders
i have my own custom function here
so my data set and it pipes into a
function and that's what this fct
display file is for it's to put all of
your functions into one place
so that if you need to edit parts your
dashboard you'll need to edit one piece
of the code
right where it's duplicated
so in this case let's say i want to
change it back to orange
now i can save this rerun the dashboard
and it should work just fine
and there you go all four graphs update
with the new orange color this applies
to any you know ggplot option or data
table option or
whatever functionality you have in your
data
um
the other advantage to
adding functions to your fct file is
everyone's favorite documentation right
dashboards and their functionalities at
this level can become incredibly complex
and so it's always good to have
a function out or excuse me functions
and documentation for those functions so
that yourself or other people reading
your dashboard code six months down the
road will understand you know what this
code's actually trying to do
and the other benefit
is you know if you recall if we run
these lines
i should be able to export from my
package
and look at that there's my custom
function
guess what happens when i put the
question mark in front of it
it builds the actual help documentation
per oxygen documentation for code so all
of this
workflow with golem and whatnot is
trying to help you standardize your your
package development standards your
dashboard development actually create
documentation for for packages down the
road
finally before we get into a little more
customization
um
there is the final file that we had open
which was this o2 deploy
so what o2 deploy does
is
when you publish your dashboards
on rcu connect they
break for good reason because they need
to have different environment variables
to connect either to you like database
credentials
or if you're using pins you need to have
your api key in there somewhere
and our studio by design you can't like
set these beforehand right so you have
to publish and then add them after the
fact
so what this does
is it does it programmatically right you
can go in and
add your environment variables you know
by yourself by hand by adding the name
and the value um what this does is it
uses the connect api library which i
believe is still in development mode so
it's not a cram package yet
[Music]
but you can load this you can load your
custom urls
ours will be you know snap finance
whatever at whatever url
and then you can connect
to the server
excuse me you set the server variables
you connect to the server
then you find the
the id for that piece of content you're
deploying
um you can paste that whatever and then
you can add the environment right here
right so in this example i'm finding
whatever i just published i get the
environment for that
published content and i add a new
variable called key
and then i set my own right set it equal
to whatever my api key is personally
right so that saves us a lot of time
with
deploying stuff in our studio connect
but i imagine you're probably asking
yourself at some point well this is
great but i don't want this like brown
and gray dashboard right i have i have
very cool purple or blue or yellow
business right i want to brand my own
dashboards
so
if you go into this theme file right
here at the very bottom
that's where you can just set your
colors so there's three colors you can
do primary accent secondary
you can emit these entirely and just
kind of you know
customize everything
line by line
i don't feel like you need to do that
but be my guest
so if i just change these colors to
i don't know
i only know so many hex codes
we'll go
that red and black
so if i run my dashboard again
it will update with these colors
so my primary is this you know dark red
this accent is this bright red and then
there's this like black bar on the left
for this sidebar option here
again there's more customizability you
can do
but that's what i've
deemed sufficient for the average user
is those three colors
um as well as the the logo let's say you
have your own custom logo to do
um
just like in a standard shiny app all of
the external assets are in the
instaff www folder
so you just add your logo here and
replace the the header
value with the new file path so
here's the file exists
then if i go into the the header back in
the r folder
here's that file path is so i'll just
replace this with you know your logo
dot svg png jpeg whatever
you can also attach urls
so whenever we publish content um the
the title and the logo will link back to
our content page
so instead of hitting the back button
or
anything like that they can just like
right click the title open a new tab
back to the content page by default it
just goes to our studio's products page
so you can change those however you want
um but with that
i believe that's it for
like the graveler dashboard workflow
itself
again i'm not going to go into you know
creating ui elements or
pin calls or anything like that because
that's
you can research there's plenty of
better documentation than i could ever
make out there for that
so we'll switch back to the powerpoint
real quick
um
that's the part where it goes back here
yeah so potential enhancements you know
if if some you've worked with this kind
of you know dashboarding or
customization before you might have
i thought of these ideas already
so as far as
you know with any code there's always
improvements to be made here's what i've
thought of for the graphic package
immediately so as of like shiny 1.5
there's a new method of calling modules
so instead of the actual call module
function there's i think
module server is what it does it has a
simpler syntax and understanding
so it'd be cool if i could convert it to
that
um
obviously with the dashboard themes
package
now you have those colors that
customization but
bslib has been integrated with shiny
already and so you can
use that more intuitively and create
cleaner colors and layouts again at the
time when i built this none of these
things existed two years ago
and then finally you know packages live
on testing right the more complex your
dashboard is the
more points of breakage you're creating
itself and so if we can somehow you know
connect unit tests
um to be put on these like dashboard
packages that would be great it's just
one of those areas that
again i don't really have a fundamental
understanding of unit testing and so i
have trouble automating something i
don't really know the ins and outs of
but in general you'll spend less time
debugging all of your parameterized code
but with that you know that's all i had
to talk about like from a high level so
i mean
feel free to ask questions about like
the the package itself you know the back
end how it's doing its things
uh but in general
graveler allows like our new developers
to
you know start building dashboards right
away we have about like a two week
onboarding period
with you know like intermediate sql in
our training and then in-house training
as well then after the end of two weeks
we give them a week to build their first
gradler dashboard that workflow
and so i mean in the turnaround of
15 business days you have people
building
you know the some of the best you know
shiny apps you can well i guess not the
best shiny apps you can make
robust shiny apps um
very very quickly so huge shout out to
our studio as well i mean the
itself was a game changer for us but the
ability to like integrate with with
github and package manager and
you know being able to install our
custom packages like graveler to use and
publish
our workflow's gotten a lot more simple
and a lot more standardized
thank you so much alan
i always say we're all clapping even
though you can't hear us if we can use
our clapping emojis here on zoom
but thank you so much for your
presentation and i also want to put a
shout out for
a great blog post that alan recently
wrote as well which walks through this
too
and includes a lot of
great links too
so let me put that into the chat right
here
but just a reminder too that you can
raise your hand on here to ask questions
and i can just call on you or you can
use slido tool to ask questions
anonymously
as well
but i see there is one over on
slido so let me go to that first
one was have you worked with the golem
team at all on the package ah no um
there i i have not um i believe i met
um one of the authors at our studio
conference a couple years ago
um just i want to get like his thoughts
on you like what golem was
but it was a very small conversation and
now i haven't worked with work with them
at all that'd be cool though but
definitely
i see um john also put a question into
slido and john feel free to jump in if
you want to ask a question live too
or add context because i'll read it
first but it's are there any plans to
include any simple
guise in the package either to link
modules to other files and or to
diagrammatically show modules and how
they fit
yes um so we've thought about that in
the past um
[Music]
definitely there's room for module
templates so i mean you can just like i
wrote box with array you can just put
this as a default and so it can make
kind of like these
these little template layouts
it's just not something i've had time to
work on in the past but that is an idea
we've had
as far as the second half of the
question
um
actually can you read it again rachel
just so i make sure i heard it right
yes one second um it was
so
of course plans to make simple gui in
the package either to link modules to
other files or to
show modules and how they fit together
yes the diagram thing um so
i don't really know how to do that from
like the a package programmatic
perspective i've done it personally just
making like in like a readme file for a
project i'll make just a quick little
diagram with either diagram r or
um
you know various flowchart packages
um so if there's a way you can do it
programmatically that would be awesome
um i do know i always forget what the
the code is
um but
there's something like they use this
package or the rs connect package where
it's like
create manual
i don't know but
whenever you search a package on crane
it has like the the big pdf right where
it links to all the functions and then
kind of displays all that you can
actually build one of those for your
dashboard and all of its functions
with just one line of code right so all
you would have to do is
um where's my
i closed the wrong file
once you you'll go this far you run dev
files you actually have access to your
um
that happens every now and then i think
it's just a version of my r thing
anyways
um once you get this far in your package
and so you can export everything
you can create that pdf somehow i just i
always forget how to do it
but that's that's what i have for for
that question
awesome thanks ellen i see
mj just asked in the chat can we get
this recording and yes i will share it
up to the rstudio youtube as well as on
the meetup page and linkedin
and twitter or anywhere that i mentioned
the meetup as well
but i did just put the playlist of all
meetup recordings there in the chat too
and again i would love to
hear from you all too if you want to
jump in and ask questions feel free to
just raise your hand on zoom or
i can even take unmuting yourself as
raising your hand
you know it's hard sometimes in these
virtual rooms but i like to imagine
we're all there in person together
ravi i see you just put a question into
the chat if you want to
to jump in
and it is what's your opinion on shiny
mobile
ah yes um
so we we looked into shiny mobile once
upon a time
um
and
as cool as it was it was just such a new
framework to do
that we had already pretty much doubled
down on like golem and graveler and this
method of building
so
we didn't
find a ton of value back then in trying
to also learn shiny mobile that's
slightly changed because
with the growth of our business you know
we have more
more focus on like our external sales
team that's out in the in the country
and so they they primarily work on
mobile devices and so that's something
we're currently trying to revisit um but
it's still the early stages of planning
so i don't really have much more info on
that
thanks alan
i'm gonna actually stop the recording so
people feel comfortable jumping in to
with other questions um but
for the recording thank you all for
watching
[Music]
you